por una ciudad con 76 mil habitantes a
la orilla del volga y con un monumento a
stalin
sus dueños alex 6 oro
empresario y admirador del dictador
soviético
[Música]
es de esos monumentos joseph esta les
eligió por el 75 aniversario de la
victoria del pueblo soviético sobre la
alemania nazi es un tributo al
generalísimo al comandante en jefe que
salvó el mundo del fascismo solo puso
esta estatua en su terreno el año pasado
y planea abrir pronto un museo de stalin
aquí habrá un edificio de 20 metros por
un edificio grande con unos 1000 metros
cuadrados
es nuestra historia es la historia de la
unión soviética y de rusia es la
historia de cada persona que vive en la
unción
stalin es mi héroe estaba esperando que
hubiese un monumento así desde hace
mucho tiempo es un reconocimiento por
sus cualidades
los campos
en realidad
no lo podemos creer estábamos pasando
por aquí y vimos un monumento a stalin
para que mi abuelo murió en los campos
lo fusilaron en 1938 un despiadado
tirano que asesinó a millones de sus
conciudadanos o el heroico líder que
ganó una guerra con un costo de 20
millones de vidas soviéticas las
opiniones sobre stalin enbor al igual
que en toda rusia están divididas muchos
no saben qué pensar
y
queremos ver el museo no sabemos cómo
será que habrá adentro siento mucha
curiosidad
ahora desde su ventana anave
directamente la estatua de stalin y
aunque no le consultaron antes de
hacerla la nueva construcción no le
molesta
nos preguntábamos qué sería pensamos que
estaban construyendo una casa y luego
vimos que era stalin no tenemos ningún
problema con eso él hizo tanto por el
país
ha pensado sobre ese periodo sobre la
era de stalin la época de las
represiones
no realmente nunca he pensado sobre eso
si uno se pone a pensar probablemente
llegue a una visión negativa aún así es
nuestra historia
por su parte álex seis oros quiere ver
estatua de stalin en todos lados
deberían volverlas a poner en los
lugares donde solían estar he visto que
muchas personas en rusia han empezado a
poner estatuas y bustos de josef stalin
despedidos por la fábrica de vidrio de
vor a comienzos del año 2000 alexei y su
madre ahora tienen su propio negocio
aquí hacemos cristales para todo tipo de
ventanas para casas vehículos y también
industriales lo suficiente para
financiar la gran pasión del excel el
empresario y su madre no aceptan
escuchar nada sobre las represiones de
stalin y sus víctimas y
esto es una mentira histórica difundida
por algunas personas todo lo que dicen
sobre los millones de muertes son
tonterías y sólo para darle otro golpe
stalin
sin embargo la familia soros también
sufrió por la terrible hambruna que
ocurrió tras la colectivización forzada
de estarlo
el abuelo de machista murió tras pasar
una temporada en la cárcel pero ella no
culpa están
instalen no lo hará esto fueron los
oficiales locales porque esta línea es
el responsable debería putin ser
responsable por lo que yo hago por
ejemplo porque es el jefe del estado
la obsesión con el ámbito militar en
rusia alimenta este negacionismo muchos
pobres están encantados con la idea de
un museo que celebre a stalin
esto
con el tacón de okaka como
pero que piensan realmente los rusos
sobre josef stalin le preguntamos en
moscú adquirirlo gov un politólogo
os dijo que la respuesta está lejos de
ser clara
y la relación de rusia con stalin es muy
similar a la relación de alemania con
hitler antes de la segunda ola de
desnazificación
hay antiestalinistas convencidos hay
estalinistas convencidos y en medio de
ellos hay una masa de ciudadanos que
conocen ambas posiciones pero no saben
cuál es la correcta esto refleja la
relación ambigua con stalin cultivada
por la élite política rusa
en cualquier caso los homenajes a esta
línea no son un tabú y rusia está en
proceso de cerrar memorial la mayor ong
dedicada a la memoria de las represiones
soviéticas